se leonardo tutti venuti sociali oggi
giocheremo un nuovo gioco in cui
potremmo essere dei lupi mannari
potremmo essere delle persone che
scappano dai lupi mannari e super
diversi lasciate un mi piace se questo
video radio dei 5 mila mi piace faremo
anche una seconda parte dell'uomo da
roma ora mettetevi comodi primo corno
iniziamo subito vediamo se capiterà
volumi mandare o che sta per iniziare
ora dobbiamo votare se vogliamo andare
nella casa oppure del villaggio marzo
saremo nella villa regata vediamo chi
capita luca io sono capitata a brooke
esempio personaggio perché viene
assegnato un personaggio a caldo e non
sappiamo chi è il lupo mannaro come
lamon gas con l'impostore il lupo
mannaro potrebbe essere chiunque e
trasformarsi all'improvviso
tu cosa sei intra della sono io quindi
stand eno taylor comandarono onoriamo un
po la casa sperando di non essere presi
dal lupo mannaro bellissima questa casa
non fossero sul tratto più bello la
partita dura pochissimo vedi manca solo
un minuto premessa vi dirò una piena e
bellissima d'oro ma dove sono finiti
tutti gli altri c'è qualcuno preso come
no no no la prossima partita allora io
sono li per sono lo stesso innocente io
sono mi sentono un civile non sanno lupo
mannaro no succede
dovevamo ha fatto scappare di scappare
dov'è lo vedi perché è vestito di bianco
che è preso anche a te no è stato preso
il lupo bianco
siamo nel villaggio ok sono capitate a
nuovamente sony
io dovrei successo con la mia il letto
medievale con la mia idea toro ho
sentito cos'è non lo so qualcuno stava
sparando dove tutto io sono fuori che
ferrari lupo loro stanno entrando poi
dentro proviamo a controllare qua dentro
rimaniamo qui vicino a forma vere non
esce il lupo è sì forse il lupo
eliminato qualcuno sì io qui vedo
qualcuno eliminarlo o non ho paura ho
paura 26 benedetto paura qualcuno
io ho paura che questo benedetto sia il
lupo mandati benedict se cambiamo aiuto
aiuto si fermano benedicono si è appreso
di qualcuno e rimase lupo alla fine a
prossima partita sono sempre un civile
innocente o fa proprio di fare anche il
lupo per una volta oppure voglio avere
anch'io le armi per colpire lungo buio
podio ci sono marchi stanno già modà qua
gli sono all'esterno
tu come ti chiami mi chiamo wayne ho
visto devo passare qui dove che stiamo
ancora qui nel villaggio vediamo cosa
capitò con un civile perché era capitato
quasi non fatti ma no purtroppo no a me
era successo lo stesso che è successo è
stato ucciso il nuovo video abbiamo già
vinto io sono leonardo de e sono
lungamente un civile uffa voglio fare
lupo
oppure come faccio prendere le armi
anch'io
vediamo se trovo qualche arma qua dentro
queste bisogna dichiarato che le ha ma
non c'è niente
andiamo se c'è qualcosa qua devo trovare
delle armi o no qua c'è qualcuno che è
stato fatto fuori rufus che faccio
scappa o contro notizie sul rapporto tra
poco dopo ok per fortuna sono più a
fuoco il lupo ha preso qualcun altro
l'ho sentito forse vince il lupo questa
volta dove sei ma sto cazzone ancora
qualche strano ecco diciamo se leonardo
tu sì tu no
[Applauso]
visto come si è trasformato è così ti
sto controllando la che viene eliminato
posso guardare cosa fai e non elimini
brooks il piano piano sta piano piano
limitato wow bello però essere lupo ok
stiamo tornando alla villa
[Musica]
io sono il cacciatore quando ti capita
la roma vuol dire che se il cacciatore
però io vengo eliminato turbarmi l'arma
e ricerchiamo il lupo o un agente
responsabilità come ha già preso adesso
vedo come si chiama brava brava con me
ne penso prima partita è ok nuovamente
un civile o che carino che sono loro
piccolo orto o no qualcuno che non vuoi
pianto aiuto no no mi ha preso subito
chiacchiere e al tonno san siro non
letto male no sono io ecco io questo non
l'ho vista aspetti si chiami nel tondo
voli veronica e all iva del servizio
simile cani metà
aiuto aiuto e ti sta per prendere a
testa per ora non vi sto per prendere il
sapore no ok ma perché questo vola è
questa i poteri magici parlando non
capisco come è comunque riuscito a
scappare
vediamo sono tutti nascosti e quel lupo
vediamole queste secondo lui
eliminato volta uno persone forse vince
il lupo questa volta non lo so perché
tanti sono ben nascosti castane
eliminato riuscire a eliminare quell'ora
sopra
credo proprio di sì vediamo ma non l'ha
visto ha visto protetto tutti non li
trova gli altri riuscirà a vincere
como questa bravissima giocate
vediamo se riesce a trovare quello
nascosto sul tetto e si usa questo viene
trasformato hai visto così non se ne
accorge ilvio trova è meglio se si
sposta l'altra per cambiare nascondiglio
vediamo andando a prenderlo molta
eccolo non ci aveva fatto che è successo
a fine partita penso che abbia vinto lui
è convinto il lupo finalmente io ho
votato il villaggio di piazza educati
alla quale piace di più il villaggio la
villa
ok me la sinistra canora civile va di
essere un lupo tu sei il cacciatore
scrivo mi fa tempo sopra ad utilizzare
l'arma devi cliccare ribadirlo in busta
leggero a me mi ami di esplorare un po
questo bellissimo villaggio
l'ambientazione davvero davvero bella
questo è quel posto tutto buio quelle
tante
o no leonardo rigby snow finti molto
male quindi sì allora il cacciatore ml
si no il lupo prima che altrove la norma
del cacciatore ma tentano così di
vederlo già preso ecco ci sono nights ii
e iii bis che se non a tutti qua sul
tetto che fu uno di loro ha le monete
che cosa penso che il lupo deve provare
a rubare le monete quindi eliminare
questo è stato il lupo è caduto nessuno
perché non ho un po paura del fuoco
forze abbiamo letto anche se siamo stati
attaccati al gruppo aperto siamo di
nuovo della villa tono folli ma non è
ovviamente un civile uva capiterò lupo
dalla prossima partita sicuramente
capiterò l'uomo che era stato ma sta
sparando a caso di vacanza da maria m io
mi sa che rimango qui vicino al fuoco se
si arriva al lupo mi dice 16 lungo
bianco dove le vicino al fuoco vicino al
fuoco vicino il fuoco
avevi detto che pechino il povero
citroen dyane a tutti ha preso come sto
osservando la vita stories che holly
piccoli diramare bene arrivando qualcuno
qua dentro
e bellissimo il lupo bianco
chi sarà di questo il lupo si è
trasformato ancora ecco la doga dog a ok
non è nessuno di questi allora io scappo
attenta sta scendendo giù aiuto non so
dove andare anche meglio è stato chiesto
al lupo
dentro dove dentro una casa con le
piante ok allora io esco fuori fatto che
il cacciatore che dovrebbe difendere ha
preso bene da o no non so dove andare
mi sa che se siete rimasti in pochi
pecoraino giù né sì né usa arrivato fi
sta prendendo un ora
sbrigatevi
siete rimasti in tre aiuta a tutto c'è
dietro certi prezzi
time vince il lupo è rimasta solo una
delle tante
andiamo nella villa adesso vediamo gli
capiti a ok io sono cacciatore purtroppo
è finalmente sono cacciatore dove il
lupo sei tu e io sono nuovamente civile
purtroppo filo come ti chiami tu
[Musica]
ho sentito ha sentito il lupo devo
pietro lupo finalmente non l'ora di
essere il cacciatore
[Musica]
che cosa sta succedendo
no a tutto il posto alla a
ora devo trovare tutti gli altri beni
quadri ei anche tu ma adesso mi
eliminato non posso nel nessuno riuscirà
a prenderti come fatto salire il sonno
vedeva volete scappare ei preso ma sica
sinistra dietro e quanti ne mancano
non lo so però hai ricevuto dei ben viva
venite fuori dove vediamo non solo uno
tenere rimasta io so dov'è dai
depurazione parigi quando rocciosa
mobili di benito immagine quindi
dovrebbe essere sul 38 stai andando che
cattiva vediamo ruggia ma ti chiamo dove
l'apporto di qua non mi cerca vinto la
partita da lupo ai primi premi jazz ha
vinto io ci credo un po nuovi interventi
le sei stata bravissima a non fare bene
questa regione del lupo mannaro sulle
bollette che ne facciamo un altro lo
stato un bel grazie a questo video
raggiungere i 5 mila mi piace farli
facciamo allora vi resta che cliccare
per vedere gli altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite può realizzare ciao